a circle with Center P has points a b c  such that angle ABP is equal to 20  degrees and angle ACP is equal to 20  degrees what is the measure of angle bpc  in degrees to solve this problem  construct the radius p a which has the  same length as the radius PB and the  radius PC then triangle p a b is an  isosceles triangle so p a b is equal to  20 degrees similarly triangle Pac is an  isosceles triangle so angle Pac is also  equal to 20 degrees then angle BAC is an  inscribed angle of the circle with  measure equal to 40 degrees so the arc  it subtends BC has twice that measure  and is equal to 80 degrees finally angle  bpc is a central angle so its measure is  exactly equal to the arc it subtends so  it's equal to 80 degrees the correct  answer is 80 degrees